his uh report about the college football
playoffs being expanded and it's real
and it could be spectacular
uh certainly got my attention and i
didn't even know that when he'd be
calling into the show
that ncaa president mark emmert would be
turning the senate commerce committee
into a two-drink minimum laugh fest who
knew that
pete pamela of yahoo sports joining us
once again here on the rich eisen show
how are you pete
i'm good uh the call to go on your show
saved me from watching ted cruz
uh take uh take issue with transgender
then say stance on transgender is that
really what's happening right is that
really what's happening
that was actually he butted in and just
diverted everything to the transgender
issue and
my phone rang and i was like this is a
good time to hit you because that is
like classic
political grandstanding because from the
top rope
yes it has been a it has been a good nap
inducing afternoon in the
senate commerce campaign so let's talk
about this uh college football playoff
expansion idea and where it is going
because the number 12
um by the way speaking of which tom
brady is speaking right now and we'll
get that sound for you
as they say in the business shortly um
that uh
12 is not the number that i would have
seen coming pete what's going on
with this possibility here so the the
history of
college football's postseason rich is
a series of uh nonsensical compromises
right it would be logical for this to go
to eight in in the next
in the next iteration but you have to
understand the compromises that got it
to four and where we are right now is an
uneasy truce between the sec notre dame
and everybody else uh
in theory going from four to eight
you go from four at large bids to only
either two or three at large bids and
for those who have
thrived off of that at large bids and
have an advantage because of the at
large bid situation
don't want in theory less
potential access so and
the notion of having eight at large is
not appealing to the pac-12 especially
which is floundering
the big 12 which is occasionally
floundering and the acc which is one
clemson misstep away from floundering
so uh and obviously the whole group of
five would wouldn't wouldn't buy for
that they want some sort of
seat at the at the table so what has
happened
and again this all has not even been
presented yet to be voted on but what
has happened in the back channels and
the conversations and the whispers
on all sides of the industry is that 12
with six automatic bids we assume
and then six at large bids becomes more
palatable to everyone
because it gives the access you want it
gives the for the
other leagues it gives the increased
access that the power leagues would want
um we can throw the big ten in there and
the the truce comes with
more at-large access for everybody so it
doesn't make sense on the surface but
when you drill down
and you go through all the competing
agendas because nobody's sitting at the
table rich saying what's best for the
game
what's best for the sport they're saying
how do we
keep our slice of the cookie and this is
the way that everybody gets to
still eat well i mean obviously this is
about money because
uh we on this show and i even go way
back to my
sports center days where i put out on a
sports center
2 a.m show and i i spent hours
researching it and looking it up and and
putting a piece together for a
16 team playoff and this is now 20 years
ago
where i went 16 and i would use existing
ball games and their sites as the sites
for
um you know quarterfinal games and you
know
top seeds would actually use their home
stadiums to host to start off
uh a tournament so i've been pounding
the table and
it's got to be money trumping all of it
because i don't hear the usual
uh old saws as to why something like
this can happen that it would a
ruin the bowl season b it would also
uh destroy the win all or nothing
attitude or sensibilities of every
single week in college football
c it would also remove the student
athletes
from the classroom like when are they
going to take their finals i would even
hear that
like you know what you know now and now
you're hearing
uh you know coaches say well we're
playing 16 17 games like a professional
schedule these guys are wiped out
there's no concern about that right now
is there well there will be concern
about that rich i i think i do think
that
is probably the biggest obstacle to this
steep of an expansion
uh health health and safety player
health and safety
the the counter that is say let's just
use the oran the metaphorical orange
bowl as an example
well if you want a kid to play his 15 16
17 game in the orange bowl
can the orange book give a thousand
dollar appearance fee for every player
or
do they have an autograph session and if
it's some metaphorical tua or joe burrow
or some transcendent star
did they get ten thousand dollars i mean
is there some monetary incentive
um as congress is discussing name image
likeness as we're on the air here
is there some sort of monetary advantage
that may make the risk more palatable i
i think that's going to inherently come
up
um it will be interesting to see what
the voice of the athlete
is um there's myriad reasons why this is
going to happen money being primary i'm
certainly not naive for that
right uh 12 is more money uh it's 11
games there are three postseason games
right now there are seven games
within the postseason contract what this
does
is you don't have the cotton bowl or
kyle pitts and every
receiver with a pulse on florida bails
out for health and safety i'm not
knocking them for bailing out mind you
that's a very wise business decision uh
you have a cotton ball where florida's
playing a game that's a playoff game
with some
juice and kyle pitts and company are
probably going to play in it so
it's interesting to see how in just a
decade the conversation has uh has
has evolved and they wouldn't even say
the word play off a decade ago they had
to call
the proposal a plus one and it got shot
down
and now um there's a very good chance
that uh
that an anchor get you know that the
enemy that they grow
and grow exponentially here pete family
yahoo sports reporter here on the rich
eisen show
so uh the idea for you know
12 or 10 right
would be uh every major conference if
you will gets
an automatic bid thus the conference
championship games would not be
uh neutered right so everybody would
still have a conference championship
game where the winner of that game gets
an automatic bid
and the regular season play would
potentially get somebody an at-large bid
if a committee gets into a room and
figures out who the
what uh if it's 10 teams or 12 teams you
could figure out who gets a buy
and then if it's 12 if it's 10 if it's
12 you just put them all in a hopper one
versus 12
and go with what what would be the split
of at large
versus automatic bids and things like
that pete
so the the presumption now is that you
go
six automatic six at large and who gets
the automatic
buy you go home site
um i guess it would be i went to
syracuse i'm not good at math rich
five plays 12 and then you just kind of
divvy it up
five hosts twelve i guess right and then
you uh
and then you divvy it up uh you you
divvied up that way
okay who would get the automatic bids
who
just the so it would be the power five
and then one from the
the rest of the crew uh the aac
certainly
performance wise has has justified that
they would probably be the leader in the
clubhouse to get that every year
um it would be intriguing if
it would be fun quite frankly and this
is probably not based in reality if the
cincinnati could play boise instead of
cincinnati playing
you know ucf or tulane or whoever in the
aac title game
one interesting byproduct of this that i
don't think
gets enough attention is that it also
juices up
all these leagues are about to go to
market in the uh in the next
four or five years and this makes the
conference championships games more
compelling because they are playing
games
now i mean there have been some uh there
have been some pac-12 title games that
have rated
about as well as the c-span hearings are
rating um because they didn't really
have any meaning because they knew the
fact 12 wasn't going to have a
champion in the playoffs well if you've
got a oregon season oregon team that's
on a late run or a utah team or usc team
or whoever
that game inherently is going to have
more meaning because you are going to be
an
entrant into the playoffs it certainly
that the sanctity of the regular season
we heard ad nauseam for decades was
going to be
um was going to be the reason why we
couldn't have a playoff but in reality
when you go to this size the regular
season race still has a whole lot of
meaning
and the conference title games
collectively have more meaning
what are the odds pete thamel that we
could actually utilize this to go
you know uh back end of the season on
down
to the beginning of a season and deal
with scheduling and
the fact that you know there's a there's
a a warm up
for the uh iron bowl game that alabama
plays
you know or who's scheduled
non-conference before
a conference season begins where you get
fewer conference games maybe
more uniform non-conference games
amongst the power five
and then you could uh maybe even reduce
the number of games played before a
playoff
in a conference schedule and a
non-conference schedule
a regular season schedule gets truncated
in a way to to
actually get some uniformity here and
some sanity and some understanding
for fans to know what to expect out of
everybody's schedule what about that
idea is that totally
what fun would uniformity insanity be i
mean then it would be like not college
athletics right you have to be
completely not based in reality well
you know in theory the schedule is a
problem yeah and the schedule's gonna
have to be adjusted
uh uniformity certainly anyone with any
common sense
has uh you know has said well we should
probably get a little bit of
a little bit of uniformity but there's
another counter to that too it's like
well the fcc
plays eight conference games pac-12
plays nine
well you're gonna get your bids from
your league title games or keep playing
the way you
uh keep playing the way you want to play
i think
the schedule it would be smart to
shorten the schedule
in some way um to allow for these games
on the back
end here's the problem money dictates
all these decisions right and
we'll hear a lot about health and safety
student athletes we'll hear a lot about
a lot
but full stadiums and tv inventory
dictate major decisions in college
athletics always have
always will rich and i just have a hard
time seeing collectively college
athletics say oh let's play 11 games
because that's just slicing money out
and we rarely see decisions that cost
money we only see decisions
that add money to week zero our friend
week zero which is
sort of the flotsam and jetsam
geographic outlier
illinois verse uh who is it is the
big week zero game quote-unquote big
week zero game this year
oh illinois nebraska that's probably the
best week zero game on paper this year
um and then there's a half dozen other
games hawaii usually plays
in it uh etc maybe that now becomes more
commonplace now we've had a couple
marquee games there
over the years i want to say florida
played by amy last year but maybe you
you move things up a little bit the nfl
expanding its schedule
doesn't help the calculus for college
athletics because
now you're running up against week 17
the wild card weekend there's not that
many games so that
helped so you know the nfl always looms
amid the scheduling decisions here
because
everyone knows where that where the
eyeballs are going to go you know
college football is not going to compete
with the nfl it's just not a
it's not a smart business choice so so i
guess
there's a there's there are a lot of
complexities as you know the
changing the fundamental dynamics of any
multi-billion dollar sporting energy
sure you know so time frame it for me
pete as i uh
as we uh we put a button on this
conversation what's the time frame
for something like that what we do know
well do you want the time frame of how
they're going to make the decision
or when we'll actually see it in in
college how about both i want to i want
everything
pete i want it all so we should have a
really good understanding of the model
that will be debated so they're going to
come out of a series of
two meetings of which i won't bore you
with the jargon film names of them
in the next couple weeks there will be a
model that rises and then that model is
going to be debated for a few months i
would think by thanksgiving we have a
press release but we're going to have a
really good sense by the end of the
month of
is it 12 is it 8 12 is the favorite
right now in the clubhouse
and maybe maybe people vote status quo
but that would be voting for monetary
status quo
um and then the thing we know most
definitively rich is that bill hancock
has said we will not see
changes for the next two seasons so the
21 season the 22 season
will look like it is look like um we're
i believe seven years through a 12-year
deal right now and so the last couple
years of that deal
is where we could end up seeing this uh
seeing these
potential wholesale changes well i hope
they do something i i really i really do
because you know this um i i would have
loved to have seen cincinnati maybe get
a shot last year
right you know i i'm serious like even
coastal carolina getting in
as the lowest seed they might have
gotten spanked by alabama but at least
at least it's it's something that you
know i'd like to see something like that
i really would like to see it
and play it out and have my kids put
brackets on the wall just like they do
in march i think it would be
off the charts i think people would love
it love it
couldn't agree more couldn't agree more
access opportunity where the sport's in
a little bit of a rut at the high end
right
and that's some of it is nick saban's
brilliance and you know dabo's hot
streak here and
you know what urban and ryan they were
able to do at ohio state sorry i had to
bring that up richard it's all good
people but
um you know there there is there is a
little bit of just the blahs
and this would just inject a whole new
energy
into the postseason and i i think
generally be really good for the sport i
just hope they really keep the player
the athlete in mind no i i agree pete
because
you know i'd love to get some sort of
variety here
uh as opposed to now with nick saban
being signed through
2029 that there is a
fourth grader strolling around the
planet right now knowing that if he
plays his cards right
he can be one of the teams in the final
game
uh for nick saban's final year like
literally that's just the way it goes
that's uh he's watching his peewee film
right now true
i'm seriously like my son's 10. like if
he plays his cards right by the time
he's 19
who knows maybe he could be out there
those genetics are strong too i think
he's got a good chance well
i just i i don't know how many members
of the tribe play for the crimson tide
off the top of my head right now but you
know
anything's possible why not him he's a
young derrick henry
thanks for the call pete i appreciate it
as always you go go back to your c-span
now
i'm sorry you must go back thank you
richard you got that's pete thammel
everybody of yahoo sports
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here